voici le top 3 des meilleures excuses du
z
raison numéro trois bambins le classique
c'est pas moi c'est la presse moi je
pense surtout que j'ai été victimes du
bombardement médiatique un cessons donc
raison numéro 3 la presse et puis le 3
mai c'est aussi un le jour où chaque
année reporters sans frontières publie
son rapport sur l'état de la liberté de
la presse dans le monde la france gagne
huit places par rapport au dernier
classement et se positionne 26e la
russie où la situation est considérée
comme très grave est 155e sur 180
maisons numéro 2 qui est la raison
principale êtes vous prêts
du coup c'est quoi c'est la forme qui a
péché ah non je pense que c'est poutine
voilà c'est poutine claire nette précise
nos téléspectateurs sur internet ont
calculé que nos missiles sarm apprendre
et 106 secondes pour frapper berlin 200
secondes pour paris et 2 100 de seconde
pour londres à la technique ou la
facette fumigènes
celata faisons tomber un certain nombre
de mythes le président qui arrive pour
exercer la fonction suprême ne reçoit
pas de son prédécesseur des codes ou à
papier où seraient inscrits
des chiffres des lettres qui permettrait
de déclencher l'arme nucléaire tout ça
et du fantasme vous avez aimé la
deuxième raison de son échec vous allez
adorer la raison numéro un vos propos
sur les réfugiés ukrainien
objectivement beaucoup de gens se sont
demandés si vous avez un coeur et hop
direct vous avez remarqué que ça vient
après l'intervention de poutine ont eu
personnellement donc s'il n'y a pas
d'intervention en ukraine il n'ya pas se
laisser dériver clôture de d'accord s'il
n'y a pas d'intervention en ukraine il
n'y a pas de question des réfugiés
ukrainien
tu te réveilles le matin et tu pleures
tu pleures le soir je ne sais pas du
tout où aller tout est détruit tout est
brisé
des civils imperturbable au près du
camion citerne
[Musique]
si on suit sa logique s'il n'y avait pas
eu de crise ukrainienne il n'y aurait
pas eu de questions sur les réfugiés et
craignent un dock il n'y aurait pas eu
de dérapage d'eric zemmour en gros s'il
s'est planté c'est à cause de ces camps
de réfugiés et de poutine ce qui est
efficace et c'est d'agir vite fort et de
laisser ensuite le pays respirer c'est
malheureusement ça chez sarkozy le
disait très bien on n'a pas le temps je
dis à mon équipe
on a suscité un grand espoir vous mettez
au boulot maintenant je vous aurais tu
es pas savent aller vite on commence à
fond et on accélère nouveauté mais
nation quand on est riche on peut mais
après vous passe plat en quoi est ce à
dire que ruquier si mélenchon est élu va
changer de maison là parce que voilà
quoi laisser des gens qui vous explique
que que au dessus de 4000 euros par mois
on est riche
qu donc on peut pas regagner plus je
veux dire après faut voir ce que c'est
mélenchon parce que life et le
sympathique dans les médias enfin il
faut voir ce que c'est pour dire son
programme un peu par ben soutenir des
gens qui sont aussi tolérant avec les
islamistes évidemment l'argent ne fait
pas le bonheur mais à quelque chose en
plus il ya quelque chose alors je vois
alors
bye happiness butt mais je préfère
pleurer en porsche mais je préfère
pleurer on a quand même du verre est
quand même tous là
ça va
thierry ardisson avait dit julien il
avait dit on en parlera tout à l'heure
il avait dit s'il fait moins de 7 % de
parts de marché du sud avait envoyé des
sms matin j'ai dit je te confirme que
bien une
cordiale il avait raté nous défoncer
partout la wii je lui sucer l'aspergent
je ne suis pas surpris
regardez ça c'est pas ça fait perdre
c'est pour ça le faisait l'histoire vous
êtes dans nos vies et marchois et c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on vous aime walt
pauvre si c'est vrai j'aime bien quand
même lancez vous restez avec un coût ok
une petite fringale mois quand on même
s'en régale pour nous aussi un petit
câlin voilà
[Rires]